but the one guy there was two guys that
were high-profile like that that there
was a hit on and/or they were thinking
about it one was Giuliani and the other
believing that was Geraldo Rivera oh
really yes and I told him this when I he
interviewed me wants us and I was on
Hannity with you Oh like you almost mic
he almost died hey everybody welcome to
another episode of hot box and I'm Evan
Britton and I might die somethin like
that sounds serious today we've got
Michael Franzese in the hotbox welcome
thank you so much to be here alright
Mike good to be here thank you so much
for joining us I don't know I mean I
think we just need to start where you
grew up
I'm on YouTube I what the on YouTube all
the time deal with have you pitching you
to I think yeah we just have to start
back at the beginning yeah let's do it
back in the beginning well I grew up in
Brooklyn
Greenpoint section and my dad was the
underboss of the Colombo family back in
the 60s so I grew up in that environment
and he was a very highly publicized you
know for some reason you know I found
out later on with all the guys around
they seemed to just pick my dad as kind
of the main guy the media guy the guy
that government was after all the time
so I grew up in an environment where we
had law enforcement around us all the
time I grew up actually hating the
police I hated them because my dad was
my hero and they were kind of like the
enemy you know always looking to indict
him arrest him always around the house
you know their tactics back then were
very different than they are today today
everything is very covert you know you
got a lot of informants a lot of you
know high to low we break the law yeah
and yeah back then they had seven or
eight different agencies following my
dad and they'd have a car parked around
my house 24/7 so wherever we went I was
one of seven kids we had a parade of law
enforcement vehicles follow
and I got into many scuffles with them
you know had many many incidents and so
I grew up hating them and a my dad he
was indicted three times in the state
for murder for grand larceny and some
other thing he beat all of those cases
but then in 66 they indicted him in
federal court for masterminding and
nationwide string of bank robberies
convicted and sentenced to 50 years it
was the longest sentence for a bank
robbery conspiracy case ever given up to
that point loses all his Appeals in 1970
and they shipped him off to Leavenworth
Penitentiary to do his time so I was you
know my dad wanted me out of this life
you want me to get involved I was
actually a pre-med student at Hofstra
University in Long Island but when he
went in I was you know I was devastated
I mean 50 years she was 50 when he went
in figure you know it's a death sentence
yeah so you know Joe Colombo was very
close to me at that time he kind of took
me under his wing I started meeting a
lot of my dad's friends and I just lost
interest in school and I went to see my
dad you know Mike I'll never forget I
said dad Mike robbery I mean you know
what is this all about and he looked at
me and he said son I was framed I'm
innocent
I'm not a bank robber and I believed him
and until his day I'm telling you my dad
did 40 years on that on that sentence
and he did it for a crime he didn't
commit
my dad was no bank robber and so I said
I gotta I gotta get you for something
they got yeah they do and they on you
they're on you he beat him so many times
I had to do something you know so you
know at that point we were in the
penitentiary in Leavenworth then he said
look if you're gonna be on the street
and once you're on the street the right
way and it was at that point that he
proposed me for membership in the family
and that's how things thought it kind of
started for me now listen how were you
when you became a made man I was uh when
I became a recruit and I was 22 yeah and
I took the oath when I was 24 two years
later I thought listen how do you your
mind feel like I'm
yeah so I'm a made guy in the
neighborhood nobody could [ __ ] with me
put their hands on me but I can [ __ ]
with you how did you do that look my
mentality I'm a young 20 cent euro guy
Hey
I don't like this [ __ ] guy but I love
his girlfriend kill that [ __ ]
that's my main time you know me if I
want this kill loan you know me if I
want that [ __ ] house he ever been
[ __ ] him if I was a mom never
so does that that took hold in your mind
you know Mike no honestly I got involved
in a life really to help my my father I
mean that was my whole motivation help
me feel feel self and absorb this stuff
from the mouth and my be so
self-absorbed yeah but you know what it
happens I mean it's a rush because you
know you got a ringside table or if you
go people give you a lot of respect and
you know you try to carry yourself the
right way you don't want to abuse the
honey but you never had that before
nothing important it's not it's never
like this I'll give you a little bit at
a time it's just all at once boom you
made
yeah but understand I grew up with it
you know I mean look I I spent my
childhood in the Copacabana meeting
everybody from Sinatra on down so you
know my dad was that kind of a guy I
mean when he walked into a place I mean
he was he was a different guy who really
looked up to him they really respected
him he carried himself well and he was
he was a tough guy I mean there's no
question about it you know so I mean I
grew up around it and I really admired
and respected my dad but when I got into
the life you know I want to do number
one I wanted to get him out of prison so
I worked hard on that and number two
honestly I want there to be the best
possible mob guy could be so one second
fifth year would it mean you know in
that life you kind of make your own way
ahead guys a give me an example we had I
took the oath in 1975 all right on
Halloween night actually the works of us
that night that took the oath and we had
a hundred and fifteen made guys guys
that actually took the oath out of the
hundred and fifteen 20 of us were
earners the other guys were just the
maids we bring in money yeah we were
earning earning really from everybody
else the other guys who got him a union
job whose
doing a little bookmaking you know
trying to scratch out a living so I was
determined to make money and I had a
head for business and I used the life I
knew how to use the life to benefit me
that way so I took advantage of that you
know when I got involved in a lot of
different things and you know I I came
upon a scam I'll tell you what happens
Mike there was a guy a guy Italian guy
around me right he kept coming to me he
had a guest a couple of gas stations on
legality at like a wholesale operation
so he comes to me and he says Mike he
says you know I got these two guys from
another family they keep trying to
extort me he said you got to help me out
because I was kind of a guy on the
island when I moved out there I did some
research on this guy and I found out
that he had testified in a case a civil
case against the governor's brother at
the time so I don't want having eaten
two of them right he kept coming back
kept coming back he said to me listen if
you help me out I got a way to defraud
the government out of some tax on
gasoline so we got my attention right I
hated the government so I said well
explain it to me so he tells me this
little thing ice all right we're gonna
go into business together so I want to
form a new company that's it so I get
rid of the two guys that were bothering
him I got him get rid them go away and I
put this guy Vinnie around me I had a
guy around he's a big guy right he was a
butcher big scar across I said a real ya
real for biases many watch this guy
Larry let's see if he's got something
tell me what he's got about two weeks
later he comes to my house on a Saturday
he used to bring me meet every Saturday
it was my butcher and he's got a box on
his shoulder
and I agree he's a gold medal hopes with
money I'm saying what are we doing with
all this meat we're having a party or
something I don't know about it he says
hey chief coming to the kitchen it ain't
meat puts the Box on the table he opens
it up three hundred and twenty thousand
dollars he said this is the first week
steak in the gas business smells like
gasoline right I didn't care what I
smell like
but he got my attention so what happened
Mike over the next eight years I took
that from three hundred and twenty
thousand that week to almost ten million
a week
we had about 350 gas stations people
weren't getting that one how many people
do you have in your crew that was
getting that money well you know I was
supporting a lot of people the guys at
work and I was kicking up to the family
I was giving them two million dollars a
week you got two million dollars a week
that buys a lot of loyalty as you know
you know what I mean so I would think of
two out hell yeah I would say go ahead
man do what the [ __ ] you want to do yeah
and so they made me a captain 1982
elevated me to that position and I
grabbed I got a deal with all the
Russian guys out of Brighton Beach you
know they were my partners to whatever
great partners like a sharpie real quick
what does it mean as a captain do you
have people under you yeah that's what
I'll tell you to rank you got a boss an
underboss a capo regime
you know consul Gary and Kansai area and
a capo regime the cop reasoning there's
a captain and then the next official
position is soldier when you come into
the life when you take the oath you
become a soldier and then you you either
stay that way you go up from there
and when when are you made whether you
have made guy you know listen at any
point no no no you gotta go soldier see
what happens dad sends me I'm now Joe
Colombo had been shot that's near 71
and Tom DiBella was the new boss he took
over he's dead now and I sat with Tom
and he says Mike I got a message from
your father he said you want to become a
member of our life is that true I said
yes he said here's the deal
from now on 24 hours a day seven days a
week you're all called to serve this
family that means if your mother is sick
and dying and you're at her bedside and
we call your service you'll leave your
mother you come and serve us from now on
we're number one in your life before
anything and everything when and if we
feel you deserve the privilege the honor
to become a member will let you know and
you're in a recruit period where you
have to do anything you know everything
you're told to do to prove yourself
worthy and you know listen people ask
all the time number one question my
killing did you ever kill anybody
do I get three three top questions
number one did you ever kill anybody
number two where's all your money buried
number three where's Jimmy Hoffa better
yeah
top questions all the time I can name
him whenever I go it doesn't matter so
you know after about two years I prove
myself worthy and then we got called in
on it was Halloween night 1975 in a
secure place in Brooklyn and we all took
an oath so then you became captain I
became a soldier when I when I came in
in 75 in 80 they elevated me to position
it did your father know Luciano yeah oh
yeah your friends yeah my dad you know
102 years old he's the oldest living mob
guy in the world well you not only your
father he was born in 1917 yeah 1917
now when you start figuring out because
you could basically do anything as an
earner yeah you can make it's just about
how you make the money we couldn't get
involved in drugs okay that time we were
told straight out if you get involved
with drugs you die what she always hands
off now what guys doing it they were
doing it on a side of it uh but you know
which it was crazy because I seen a lot
of guys get killed over it yeah were you
and John Gotti associate I was friends
with John you know John and I I tell you
about John why do we like him so much
no I mean so much that the psyche of the
society was I think number one because
he he made no bones about who he was I'm
a mob guy I'm god I'm up guy and I want
to be anything else that's it so he was
true to that and the way he carried
himself you know he just he became a
media star you know I want he kept
beating the government and you know what
I mean
but socially he was great our good times
we would meet in clubs all the time
business he was very hard to deal with
very hard but you know we got along we
had a few scrapes he and I but I like
him I like his family I still know his
face you're locked up at the same time
yeah we were yeah we like the same thing
at each other play cause we played car
yeah we were robbed we were an MDC
together we waiting trial yeah well you
ever locked up with Sammy
I was yeah in the same place touching
distance yeah what was that like
you know I always say this on John
Gotti's worst day he was a better guy
than Sammy yeah on his worst day I mean
I wasn't a fan of his he had kind of a
Napoleon complex and it was a small guy
and he was just very arrogant so a lot
of people didn't get along with him you
know he was a different crew than me but
we still not get along but I'll tell you
this Mike I know how you feel about it
but it's a guy that admitted to 19
murders and the government makes a deal
with him and puts him back out on the
street I mean this is the time stone
they want to they want to yeah but I
mean come on 19 murders you make a deal
with a guy like that and put them back
on the street you know what he was doing
then he got involved in ecstasy yeah in
a club that I was involved with on on
Sunset Boulevard in order to keep the
yeah I'm at Key Club remember to keep
Sunset I was involved with that and he
was there was selling ecstasy in the
club
he just got out about a year ago go
family yeah stay on a street name job
yeah yeah is the idea of you know
letting a guy like that out letting him
come back to society there's the idea
that you're getting something bigger in
return like what is the psychology of
that of that system they needed Gotti I
mean they wanted him and he beat them so
many times he was you know thumbing his
nose in their face and they wanted him
and they were willing to make a deal
with anybody really yeah you know you
know what happened I'll tell you what
happened in our life there was there was
a lot of respect there was also a lot of
fear what happened in our life when guys
on the street started fearing the
government more than they were fear in
our life yeah that's when everybody
started flipping and turning and it was
it was unbelievable when did that change
happen really in the 80s you know when
they started using that racketeering law
I was in I was in the next cell with
Sammy and I'll never forget he was we
were in NBC and we were talking through
the you know through the air
conditioning vent not inking whatever
was in the floor because you couldn't
talk at a wall there but we got talking
and for some reason he didn't sound
right to me you notice things were not
sounding the right the way he was
talking and then they came and took him
away not too long after that huh but you
know I kind of resent this because
people say all the younger guys really
couldn't stand up like the older guys
but my answer to that
you know if thirty forty years ago
you've got ten years you got 15 years
anybody can do that you do seven eight
years you get on our parole you go back
to your life today they hit you with a
RICO charge it to 60 you got you got 20
years right off the bat
no more parole meaning you're doing 17
and a half minimum and if you get 20 on
a RICO case you're lucky I was facing
150 years Wow honey and they would have
gave me every bit of it because when I
was in MDC I'm watching these guys going
to trial Mike they're coming back 300
years 90 years I said man I'm the
youngest guy they're gonna give me five
thousand years I'll never get out of
jail but you know I took my shot anyhow
I mean I I took a plea and I did my time
but fortunately I beat him a couple of
times so they wanted a conviction on me
but that's why guys didn't stand up
nobody stands up it's very hard you know
you know one guy that's my dad my dad
didn't give him five million years he's
never seen a word to anybody he was that
kind of a guy why don't you think hey
why do you think he's um what do you
think it's nothing for people need to
live that life they need to make sure
they feel this for me I'm not doing this
cold I don't care that can kill me why
do you think they have to have that
mentality to be part of that life yeah
it's that mentality like some people
that's not even part of life just like
that why would why would somebody want
to do something like that you need to be
involved in a life where to be an
informant know don't give a [ __ ] I don't
care they give me a hundred years you
know there's just there are people say
but I think I'm not like that no no do
me one rear got it like that yeah and
that's my dad well Persico jr. my former
boss I mean these guys they're just
they're old-time guys yeah yeah and it's
like I'll die in jail that's it
my dad my dad the worst thing you could
ever call him missus that you're an
informant you can call them and never
that he just can't accept it it's not
part of his many people take the life
that well that life thought gave them
honor even lean so that's what he did so
something yeah it Mike you know what the
best thing that happened to that life on
the street the movie The Godfather yeah
I'm telling you I was I was younger than
it was in myself it was in 70s but you
know Joe Colombo was involved in that
movie I remember really oh yeah
he actually edited the script he took
the original script had the word mafia
all over it he took it out he made
changes in it and they had no choice
they had to do it but after that saves
the family after that movie came out guy
started to walk differently they started
to dress stiff treated them differently
treated him different being black of
some Browns it being I get mafia guy
that's [ __ ] like God you can get away
with anything
the cops [ __ ] with nice you never got
a ticket the cops brought you presents
rich et across the cops you know me yeah
nice rule the [ __ ] van Gogh the big
kind of guys respect you didn't this
with you yeah they don't know your
[ __ ] name
you don't even meet them you meet that
[ __ ] boys they're business partners
are their lawyers to business with you
there's the truth hasn't living that
life that's all everybody I always had
all that they wanted to be involved if I
wanted to be involved with tomorrow they
had a history of that you're gonna make
some money be involved these Italians
they're gonna get you money and you
gonna go to jail either and I mention
for that you know the reason for that
you know there's these other groups out
there but if you take the drug business
away from them they all collapse and I'm
not knock I'm just as the truth yeah but
with us we survived and prospered for
well over a hundred years under some
very tough conditions the reason for
that we infiltrated every fabric of
society from the white house right down
to the guy on the street in the numbers
business we control the unions in this
country
you control the unions you control the
country because you got all that money
behind you for political purposes to buy
your way into things you got everybody
at your beck and call
you call this like it built [ __ ] built
man they build an every day ten millions
of times you can't getin business the
country stops we start
you don't want the country to start with
a [ __ ] you call a teamster he
would be on slavery yeah you call a
strike with the team [ __ ] you got two
and a half million truck drivers stop
yeah you taught you call a strike at the
docks
nothing comes in and out of the country
that's tremendous control yeah
definitely
take us back into you became a captain
you're earning a lot a lot of money a
lot of income for the family what so
what are the businesses then what are
what are your options what did you do
well you know like I said I had a head
for legitimate but look I had a gambling
operation I ha 12 or 13 bookmakers
working for me you know and the reason
for that if there's a bookmaker on the
street we're not gonna allow it to
operate unless he's kicking yeah so
they're always yeah so we had we had a
bunch of look and that what a fresh new
thinking yeah why would you be on my
corner this is where I make my - my
favorite live that why would you be a
sum of money we're not getting a part of
it you know and you know I had a head we
had the Union a lot of union control -
at one time you know I had the security
guard Union with me
we had the security guards in nine
nuclear power plants around the country
whoa
so nine nuclear power plants were
controlled by a mob controlled Union you
know I don't know if you know that deal
but a nuclear power plant after it shuts
down you have to have security there for
a hundred years whoa that's the law even
after it shuts down they don't use it
anymore because of you know it's toxic
and already laughter so you know I had I
had some union control and you know I
had a lot of legitimate business I had a
bunch of car dealerships at a leasing
company kind of cost ourselves I had
Mercedes and I had Chevrolet a Mazda
had a big leasing company so we're doing
that and I had a production company out
in LA we were making movies and you know
you got a couple of restaurants and you
got a piece of stuff because guys are
coming to you all the time they're
looking for money so you give him a few
bucks you take a piece of the business
and that's how it goes and I was very
aggressive so I had a lot of stuff going
on back
did you ever meet the guy Iceman I never
met him I yeah he was she was around us
I you know I'm like I don't think I met
him I really don't
yeah and I didn't know at the time you
know sometimes you don't talk about a
certain guy but yeah I mean what did
your father think about Capone you know
my dad's funny yeah you know he didn't
think real highly of them that's weird
yeah he really did and you know Capone
came out of New York even though that
yeah came out of Brooklyn to me wasn't
that tough no no that tough and booklet
they believe Brooklyn after we know
that's right oh yeah that's right oh
it's just like no [ __ ] yeah interesting
how how far back what's the lineage how
old is is the mob
it's the beginning of time ancient right
mafia started in Italy with the French
but imagine it had there been back then
with Hannibal during that time - yeah
under hell not have secret societies
when you have civilizations hey way back
and then you know they immigrated here
to America and it started in the early
1900s for 1900 American Mafia and stuff
yeah it's American when you have him in
the gone system you know time
yeah how can it not be going on I'm
probably big business in the Mafia now
cooperate America's mafia now if you
don't do yeah sell you out will crush
you we starve you out you don't take
this deal shame shame Machiavellian
thought process yeah yeah what is the
state of it now you know it still exists
uh-huh it's it's certainly not going
away not in my lifetime but it's not the
same it's really not you know the the
government did a I guess you got to say
a good job starting any 80s and I give
Giuliani to credit or blame he put the
last day at Kauffman he really started
to use it the racketeering laws
effectively it was him so you know in
case it can print in my time
yeah he you know and he was Italian - he
just he gave the story that he visited
Joe Bonanno and he got insulted over
Bonanno
book that he wrote that time so he
decided to go after the mob but I
believe you know that was he came down
from Washington to become the US
attorney in Manhattan saw high-profile
uh-huh and he picked the biggest
high-profile organization he went after
the mob and made headlines and it was
good for his career
now as a guy like Giuliani and danger of
you know having a hit put on him or
anything like that you know in our life
we really didn't go after the law
enforcement early it's different you
know kill everybody family government
they don't care don't care it's a matter
of fact they wanted me to do a book
signing in Italy and I said you guys are
out of your mind
you get a body double or something I
ain't going italy because they they
don't care over there but we never did
that but the one guy there was two guys
that were high-profile like that that
there was a hit on and/or they were
thinking about it warm was Giuliani and
the other believe in now is Geraldo
Rivera oh really yes
and I told him this when I he
interviewed me once I said I was on
Hannity with him oh like he almost mic
he almost died yeah I told him
off-camera I said there was two guys
Geraldo that we really hated one was
Giuliani any other was you and he turned
white sir sir okay now I said they're
dead said I ain't gonna hurt you but you
rather do Rivera tried so hard when he
was coming up and had this showed he is
one to be accepted so what the crowd the
love them so bad everybody yeah he was
yeah he was he made his name on the
empty safer now Capone's safe yeah Al
Capone yeah
if anything you would have wanted to
work with law enforcement as much as
possible yeah well you know whatever you
know there's so many guys look we had
five families in New York and among all
of five families we had about 750 guys
that took the oath actually took the old
you had a lot of associates but there
were so many of us that we had so many
relationships we had cousins that were
cops uh-huh no we had a neighbors that
were cops so we were able to get
they liked us you know so we were able
to move around pretty good you know it
was um they did the scientific study and
they realized a cup psychology in the
criminal psychology is pretty much the
same yeah you know I mean they pretty
much the thing yeah make sense yeah you
got to have a certain mentality be
Potter dad I mean look
yeah well that brings me to my next
question is you cross paths with Donnie
Brasco yeah before yeah my friend that
was an FBI agent was friends with him I
thought wow his friends would would
lefty you know his main guy they're here
we all right yeah Rogerio he was by the
way a great great move amazing I think
that Pacino the guy lefty they made
everybody fall in love with left that
was Pacino's best roll so good but uh so
I crossed paths with him because they
were from Greenpoint too
once or twice in that life I always
tease him nice man I'm so glad I didn't
do business with you clay I've done a
few things with him afterwards you know
sorry I left him in the venue so sorry
brother man yeah he did yeah him and
Sonny black he said he felt bad but you
know he had to do what he had to do yeah
cuz you know he left he didn't get
killed over that but so liked it oh wow
yeah and the movie where it shows him
taking off his stuff like he was gonna
get killed he died of natural causes but
Sonny black got killed over Donnie
Brasco
I'm glad lefty think yeah Wow how was
that a one-in-a-million thing or did
that happen a lot
okay no it didn't happen a lot yeah I
mean they I just didn't do that homework
on him you know they really didn't I
mean you got to go back you know I don't
know if you noticed Mike they had a big
undercover investigation on me to get
Don King he's poor shadowboxing really
yeah
I'll tell you how it happened that have
been so [ __ ] interesting no I I tell
you die he's pretty smart though they
they send these two guys to me and they
told me they want to get into one with
an undercover FBI age
the other was around Muhammad Ali the
guy been a name of Reggie I forget his
last name he took him out of prison
because she knew the boxing game and
they come to me and they say look we got
money and we want to get into the boxer
they let him out of I let him out of
prison they said we want to be in the
boxing game but we want to go at the
high level I said well who do you want
to meet they said Don King so I I roam
ants these guys for about six or seven
months before I would bring them to Don
I get all out Sharpton who was running
with us at the time and I said al had
the cowboy head or the two guys yeah
those are the two pass because they
posed as drug dealers from South America
so I told him I said look I'm not gonna
bring you to King and let's say see the
money so the FBI sits in a bank account
up and they put they show that they got
15 million dollars in a bank
so Sharpton sets up the meeting with Don
and that we go to see him before I let
these two guys in the room I go see Don
I said Don listen I only traced these
guys six or seven months I verified the
money but at this table don't see
anything out of the way talk straight
tell him how to business runs do
everything legit all right and he does
he doesn't say anything wrong it does
everything right and we walk out in a
room and now I'm getting at my so you
got to put up the money
and the FBI wouldn't allow him to go
that far and then the whole thing fell
apart after that but but what do they do
this um this [ __ ] look at some papers
a let's get in there what do they do
they just thought these investors
there's something up they start an
investigation they shave where it leads
that's it so that was a you never heard
of another instance of a guy
infiltrating her you know not to the
level it that Pistone did no I mean he
was tried to become turncoat semester I
mean it was all to tell you about the
relased guy to fill out the windows a
human at that time kid rellis remember
the guy that it was or a beer Ellis yeah
yeah yeah they threw him out
yeah yeah murder incorporated all that
stuff oh yeah no but with I mean Pistone
they were gonna they wanted to kill
somebody
they were gonna bring him on ahead and
they were gonna make him or they were
gonna straighten him out
I mean he got that far and obviously
they had a stop at that point but he got
that far wow they really accepted him
Sonny black I had loved him well so tell
me do you have some people that are just
born and forth that you get involved
they just want them breathing
sorry they would do was guys there that
Roy DeMeo did you know him I knew Roy he
really that kind of guy he was
yeah that's interesting how violent was
it how prevalent was the violence town
by Roy DeMeo instead Roy DeMeo yeah he
was his crew was just a wild crew I mean
they they chopped up bodies they put
people in Samanta I mean they did they
want the old distance yeah they touching
these people could be great Greg Scarpa
was a guy with us they call him the Grim
Reaper he was another guy that he was
tough to be around you know he had that
kind of that cloud over him you know
what I mean Mike it's kind of like Thor
yeah yeah actually trying what you say
may be careful anybody outside the crew
what they think yeah it's kind of one of
those guys you know there were some guys
that I know that just enjoyed that and
there's other guys that just did what
they had to do I mean we were all
capable we had to do it it's yeah I'm in
a room I gotta bathe me for a guy get
put to sleep yeah that must be a trip
right yeah it's tough
that's always where happening that I'm
building up here you never saw before
the NEC go down even though it might got
a you know one of the horrors of that
life you know what happened to you you
don't know what you were in trouble your
best friend walks you into a room you
don't walk out again
so when they were I had it I had an
incident where some Newsday article came
out paper on Long Island and he said
that I was making billions of dollars so
the boss Persico at the time was kind of
questioning me says Mike what's what's
going on they're saying you're making
billions I said jr. I'm giving you two
million dollars a week you're not happy
I said I'm taking all the risk it's
everything here so one night they I
walked into a
a room I didn't think I was gonna walk
out again I'll be honest with you it was
kind of a death walk for me and people
have said to me why didn't you cut and
run it was almost it was robotic it
wasn't like you know I'm a macho guy was
just hey if this is if this is the
because we're am I gonna run right what
happened
well I'm here all right so it was all
right but now they started questioning
me about money and grilling me with my
Russian partners because you know they
had tried to go to my Russian partners
to see and and they were pretty loyal to
me so they told not everything's on the
up-and-up so they were trying I was a
younger guy that we're trying to scare
me a little bit at that point make sure
they knew that who they were the boss
and so on and so forth because I was you
know I had a pretty big crew at the time
this was jealous too little jealous why
I don't want to say but you you know how
it goes you know it's because the
jealous yeah yeah oh yeah a lot of guys
went down for the wrong reason man you
see a guy that started out you start out
before him he knew the [ __ ] guy
hanging out in the cold nifty no he got
a [ __ ] Club he got a dignity all
these [ __ ] [ __ ] on them the nice
cars and stuff and you started before
Muse here before him yeah yeah cuz you
know when I started no I mean I had a
jet plane I had my own helicopter you
know I was driving all the guys around
when I started from nothing now he got
that and the old time is they kind of
resent that a younger guy you know
you're kind of resented so so he said a
car magnet um the old man who's the guy
used to be with Luciano know this guy
Carlo Gambino he musta hated your guys
boy you know I do guys out there he
would go with the quiet game with the
hate you guys shown yeah he was regarded
you know the money's under the mattress
and I'm just the salesman and nothing I
he didn't want to be by he was she was
that kind of very low-key guy I know in
those guys yeah and Phil into that yeah
I know a lot of the sly guy we all
respected those guys too yeah Philly
spent a lot of time there upstate New
York you know Russell Bufalino there the
movie that's coming out now is all about
the idea the one that Scorsese did with
net perhaps man yeah
oh yeah it's gonna be a good movie it's
gonna be a good movie that's the guy
that allegedly you know killed off huh
all right
huh so he wrote a book and they're doing
a movie everybody's in it now it's gonna
be a good movie no doubt Oh
Scorsese always comes yeah Goodfellas
Goodfellas great movie Casino who would
you guys kill and why would they be
killed well you told straight out
obviously you turned snitch you're dead
uh-huh
you get involved with drugs you're dead
you dishonor another man's wife how do
you order how do you think they allowed
you how do you get out of a lot how do
you prove this guy's lying a lot of
times you got a lie to prove that you're
innocent well you know here is it here's
the thing you know when you sit down on
another made guy we ever sit down or we
have a dispute right you're a made guy
I'm a made guy if I call you a liar I
lose the argument at the table you
always had to be respectful you couldn't
call somebody else you lie you had to
try to outsmart them to win your point
because if you break the rules at the
sit down you lose automatically so you
had a you had to learn how to be very
cagey and very technical not to fall
into a trap not to let somebody get you
so upset that you could name are you
telling me what this guy named the
Anastasia guy wasn't how but you taught
me Albert Anastasia talk down and had a
decent conversation with the person
can't do it at the table I'm telling you
now maybe if you're the boss you do what
you want but you're not supposed to
really yeah you can't
not yelling at somebody and if you yell
you're gonna yell in private yeah there
was a lot of times when another made guy
called him every name under the Sun but
if we were with people never but it was
just me and him in a room because then
he'd I call him a lie he calls me a lie
we each deny it there's no problem but
you can't do it in front of another guy
it's all order and everything that we
since the beginning yeah oh yeah even
more so among the old-timers there now
yeah
such an interesting world ma'am and did
they like Louisiana did your father like
yeah my my dad liked him yeah
like lucky like how did he feel about
the deals and stuff in the game like it
like you know Lansky liked him yeah he
told me about him he thought it was a
very quiet guy Lansky no sir
yeah yeah yeah my dad you know he sold
he knew everybody what was it that got
you into prison I ended up by they took
me to trial four times Giuliani tried me
on a big case I beat all four cases well
and after a they were coming after me on
the gas business and my partner was
turning informant he got locked up on
another case they pulled him out if we
had a compound in Panama and we were
actually paying Noriega for stuff well
and so when he he went on trial for some
other deal that he had and halfway
through the trial he says to me I'm not
going to jail he says we got a compound
I'll run everything from there so he
leaves he goes to Panama because at that
time there was no extradition between
Panama in the United States or you know
what the feds did they went in there in
the middle of the night and he kidnapped
him and brought him back to Florida whoa
put him on a plane broke door down in
his house pulled him out put him on a
plane brought up to Florida as soon as
he got there he started flipping on me
so I know I'd have problem with the gas
case so after I beat Giuliani's case I
had leverage with the government because
they wanted a conviction so I made a
deal I got a ten-year sentence at a
twenty million dollar restitution and I
had to give up the plane helicopter and
I wouldn't did my time but what year was
that that was in I took the plane 85 and
I did eight years on on the 10 which was
maximum but I just knew that the life
was in trouble I said forget it I get a
convicted here on something gonna give
me a hundred years I'm dead so I had a
shot to do it and I said let me take my
chance I'd rather do a couple of years
in jail and come out and least have a
life and I was still a young guy you
know at that point so you remember the
hit
well if they hit that dumb when he took
over when God he took over and Tom got
Paulie Castellanos yeah yeah it's box
yeah you know what happened when they
have well you know we all down when they
we all knew it yeah we all know what
yeah when did things like that they
don't Ward circulates quick yeah yeah do
families have fright leaf a.m. the
Gambino family and the Luque do they
ever have wards with each other no that
stuff ended back in the 30s and 40s
whenever there's a warmth you know it's
always a civil war it's always within
the family huh you know power usually
was gonna be the boss and never with
another family no never with another
family at least not in the last 50 60
years but we had we had we were pretty
rough family in Africa we always killing
each other always huh over doesn't
happen like this Sam I'm gonna cage you
again being alright and we're in family
with cousins we're cousins and you have
a problem with a guy and so on and I'm
mad because you man this man so can your
cousin kill them yeah that happened
before you yeah I'll figure that yeah
I'm sure that would happen my family
than this family this guy pissed me off
he did somebody killed my friend a
family member
yeah yeah we always helped each other
out stuff like that you know what so the
the stuff the stuff between family
members that was all somebody lied to
somebody or dishonored businesses fueled
you know if your umbrella territory this
belongs to me and you shouldn't be
involved you know to deal ahead buddy
we got involved in a flea market believe
it or not which was big business in New
York I know if you remember and blowing
big business right so I had a guy in
there who was an accountant and he had
two partners one of the partners was it
was a drug addict he was selling drugs
in a flea market so a guy comes to me he
says Mike if you get rid of this guy for
me I'll give you a piece of the market I
said okay so we chased the guy out of
the market about a week later I get a
call from John he's Michael you know
that kid is with me I said John how is
he with you we never
your name he's dealing drugs and I
supposed to be doing that we threw him
out nah he's with me I know him a long
time he only made a mistake with the
drugs he's not really a drug addict
that's okay let's look at his arm you
know but anyway so we have this whole
big dispute over it you know we had to
sit down with the boss and everything so
what I said I said look I can never get
along with John in business I said so
I'm gonna ask him to buy me out
knowing that John would never take that
you know I don't buy you you don't buy
me out I buy you out so at the end of
the day did you have a big ego oh yeah
really well he really did my I gotta say
it I mean look I admire talking negative
about him but he had a big ego tell me
what is this they didn't mean me yeah it
was awful he was but it was fun to be
around you know yeah me it was good that
way but so he ended up buying me out of
market well he took it over and they
collapsed about three months later but
they probably took everything in the
mark and brought it home you know who
knows we got a little sketchy for a
minute yeah but again it was never like
do you ever meet Carlo Gambino I met him
when I was a kid who's Carlo died in 75
but I met it with my dad yeah yeah 76
all right yeah but yeah well from the
outside from the outside in it can feel
like every moment as like as a life and
death moment yeah even know is it that
way you feel that way when you're in it
or you just accustomed to the stakes so
you don't think about it that way well
you do at times you know you look you
always have to be a little bit on edge
not I don't know if that's the right
word you got to be on your guard always
because you know if you make a mistake
especially if guys are gunning for you
like I said I'm a younger guy I'm making
all this money you know like my boss
kept wanting me to introduce my guy
Larry to him the guy was pawn this week
and I would refuse I said look I don't
know if this guy is gonna stand up if I
bring him around everybody and he goes
bad I'm gonna be in trouble for it so I
said I'll keep him with me and that was
a good excuse so they could never meet
him because I know why they want to meet
him at some point in time they
they take them from me you know they
take them away from me but but uh so you
always got to be watching yourself you
know you can't make a mistake because
you pay with your life so you got to be
very careful you know I'm that way even
told to now I mean I'm walking down the
street one of them they can't talk to
you for a minute please
you know what everybody thought these
amenities my gif I'm crazy [ __ ] I never
know what's gonna have you look I had a
good guy around me that I knew go of my
life and he was involved in it and he
got involved in a case with the boss's
son it was a drug case and so he came to
me and he said Mike they're gonna kill
me over this I said they ain't gonna
kill you they're not gonna he said naw
dude you're gonna make me take the
weight because the boss's son is not
gonna go down for this hmm
I said tonally don't worry about it I'm
gonna straighten it out before I could
straighten it out he ended up killing
himself
that's how scared he was gonna get K
blew his brains out in in a phone booth
I was like stunned so I mean you know
you you you know you got to be on your
guard you can't let your guard down you
can't make mistakes that you know could
be very costly hmm I'll tell you
something that that'll shock you should
in 1986 they wrote a article in Fortune
magazine 250 biggest and most powerful
mob bosses in the country was huge
always half the magazine and they
featured six of us I was one of the six
they had a chart with the 50 of us on
there according to rank and wealth and
power and all that now I was number 18 I
was a youngest guy on the list
gadi at that time was number 13 he
hadn't been made [ __ ] and don't ask
me how they make a list like that never
ask from a tax it was all nonsense but
it sold a lot of magazines what his with
not nonsense out of that list of 50 33
years later 48 and I'm a debt well one
of them right now is doing life in
prison and I'm the only one that's
walking the streets so that's the kind
of life that is right 48 guys dead in 33
years that's a lot Wow but then I can I
go from it I'm from Brooklyn I go like
this I look at it like this
I wasn't going nowhere anyway where was
I going you know yeah I going anywhere I
was gonna dive right on the neighborhood
not a [ __ ] bench doing nothing that
time I sleep when they're Dyson's just
walking up stairs
you know what was that doing I had a
chance to [ __ ] girls I would've never
[ __ ] before my life have live in
houses I would have never lived in my
house drive cars I've never would've
drove in my house be respected by people
who would never respect me if I wasn't
in this business
that's worth my life I give me Mike this
that's what's my life there's this rule
you know I always say if you're a part
of that life and you die of old age and
you die free you've really accomplished
something there's a stuff life yeah and
like you know I mean you're a survivor
come on no doubt about that you get
through all that stuff yeah I don't
knock those guys because I know what
they're facing if they don't get
involved with this literally I don't I
don't want to say stuff but from my
perspective this is always gonna be
better than this yeah something's gonna
be always better than nothing how you
gonna know respect people disrespect
your mother in front of you your wife
your sister in front of you this is
nothing no one dare carry your parents
bags they walk them upstairs they help
them which life do you want yeah he's
right look you come into their life they
tell you listen wherever you go around
the world you're gonna have somebody to
back you up
nobody's gonna have a screw your mother
your sister your brother you got high
brothers all over the world how do you a
beat with that
oh you a big strong guy they could check
that real easy they'll need a bully at
the bat yeah you know makes sense I I do
a lot now with with professional sports
yeah I wanted to get to them you
interviewed Nick Saban didn't you yeah
yeah I'm gonna be there Friday I'll tell
you what I do I talked to him about
gambling they were very worried about
gambling yeah I played football I
remember those talks all the time did I
who'd you play for I played for Arizona
Wildcats for college and then I played
for the Jaguars and the Bears oh okay
well I I don't think I don't think you
came and spoke to us but we definitely
had
the gambling talk so I was gonna I was
curious that's what you talk about with
them yeah gambling in relationships with
and yeah just give them life lessons you
know because lot of these guys think
they're invincible yeah so here's what I
do I tell I tell it cuz I did over 300
colleges right I call the universe it
football team but a lot of times all the
student athletes but I said look I want
the biggest guys in the front row
biggest guys all the line men all the
biggest guys yeah and then I'll get
through and I'll go to one guy said hey
you big guy right six-foot not like you
yeah I just stand up there look at me I
just stand up were you free three times
my size stand up right so they'd get up
and I said man I wouldn't mess what you
want to feel I said you'd tear me up I
said forget about it I said I want to
tell you this and I'll put a little line
down answered you cross over that line
you come into my world and I'll leach
I'm gonna make a [ __ ] out of you and I
gotta tell you Mike they like look
around and it's silence in the room I
said now sit down and you sit down and
you know because look you got you gotta
make an impression with them because
gambling did [ __ ] you up man I got to
tell you it's I see some of these guys
get destroyed over it you know I'm like
you know you know I was in the house I
was training for a fight when they said
they didn't want me to be a lot of strip
didn't let me know though so they put
this big mansion right and I said to
myself wow I like this I like to buy
this house I said I was saying I'm how
much is this house he said well we don't
know right now because we just got it
from somebody they had a debt to the
hotel you know wow this house its losses
a so we have to be tell now there's a
fellow in the house mouses right talk to
the guy did you buy the house they won't
let us out no
luckily gambling was never something I
was that interested in know what it was
not attractive to me as you see my
friends you know they're little got a
little entertainers right they losing
social minds just so meek I try to get
my stuff they want to fight me they
never had a mean bone in their body
uh-huh yeah it's just so pissed
the sauce and cooking car you know we
had we had guys from beyond from the
Jets and you know a lot of the local
teams gambling without sure I get a
bookmaker call me up this is back in the
eighties now and he said Mike so-and-so
player he's into us for 200 grams should
I cut him off I said why would you cut
him off
you're writing it down on a piece of
paper I says let him get into you for a
half a million and then bring him to me
and for sure they would so they come in
I said I should sit down I said you owe
me some money
how you gonna pay well you know it's not
like today we're making millions back
then it was a little difficult
I'm a big fan of you I love the team you
don't have to pay me now you're gonna
pay me five points a week on the morning
every Friday you bring it here in cash
and if you don't come here we'll send
somebody to see you don't worry about it
go out and have a blast
well they'll do that for five or six
weeks and you know what's happening
they're running to another town that
button with another bookmaker to get
more in debt bring them back say what
happened you missed last week and that
big let me tell you how we're gonna work
this out you're a quarterback first
three times you get the ball you put in
and any other receiver your running back
yeah you pick like you put it on the
ground too right that's it
we'll worry about the rest you do that
for me I'll clear the debt that's it wow
what are you gonna do yeah oh you want
me to do it you want me to do yeah okay
cuz really what did they lose entry on a
piece of pavement I like to you know you
gave him anything you know but and a lot
of it I got to tell you about athletes
they're not good gamblers no it really
not I can't tell you how many of them
got in trouble well pleasure seekers
yeah big-time
pleasure sequined adrenaline me the rush
exact oh yeah hold if they know we're in
a hole dig give me the rough looking
she's so competitive and what is a
gamble you it heightens the state oh my
god raises the stakes yeah I said I had
buddies gambling in hotel rooms on the
plane you know to and from games
all the guys were [ __ ] guys loved
hey I see once this is funny because you
know I love Jordan to me still my
all-time favorite basketball player but
we were at a security meeting what's
with the NBA Michaels playing the head
of security for Table Tennis they're
playing for five bucks right of course
Michael wins he wins every day so
Horace's got is is a warm-up suit on and
Michael says where's my five bucks all
right so I don't have any money it's up
on my room he looks nice to go up and
get it he goes up he comes down he hands
Michael the five bucks I witnessed at
all and our salute I said Michael five
bucks this is yeah this is my trophy I
beat you as soon as pocket and walks
away I said wow this is intense yeah
yeah you know but I get it I really get
it yeah I'll be honest yeah I'm not a
gambler I didn't have dup but I enjoy a
game when I got money on it just you
know I get more in oh yeah for sure
you know I gotta be honest yeah I know I
know guys who love it it's just really
good off I mean look at the businesses
now that are being legitimized with like
draftkings and all the fantasy football
it's crazy
listen I'll never forget when off-track
betting came in to New York right the
cops came to us we're gonna put you guys
out of business
I should really let's see what happens
because what happens wolf track betting
you got to go in you got to put your
money down at the window they don't give
you any credit and what happens if do
you lose that money you come back to the
bookmaker and you because we give you
credit and you gamble it actually made
us more busy because now more guys were
gambling than they were before
Wow and you always lose you're gonna
lose at some point yeah in fact an elf
this is even tough today I don't you
can't for some reason I don't know if
it's him anything you can tell me people
like doing business with them all oh
yeah it's exciting no I don't know why
because maybe it's been so long they've
been accustomed people uncomfortable
with the debt right now we're really
uncomfortable from last year last what
since the since the eighties seventies
sixties he's been uncomfortable with the
government you know you know why I'll
tell you what everybody thinks that we
would sit in our social clubs and we
would target a certain business didn't
happen like that
they would come to us why hey we need
money we're never gonna snitch on you we
can help you we'll protect you
they would come to us this whole guest
thing the guy came to me I didn't go
right it happened like that all the time
they come to you head figure this guy's
gonna protect me he'll give me money you
can't tell the government I pay you next
week I promise I pay you next week
you can't tell him that he doesn't hear
that he doesn't see that he doesn't hear
anything uncle so yeah he thinks you and
kick you out and takes everything
exactly did you ever have to [ __ ] people
up for their gambling debts or for their
debts in general that wasn't a mob
person you know what most of the time
you didn't have to do that because just
there if they're scared enough that
they're gonna come around yeah but every
once in a while you had to make an
example out of somebody because they
were just too wild Oh
- well you know the thing is they would
they'd lose money with you go to another
bookmaker here like we didn't know we're
all connected but we all knew what was
going on I think they don't yeah yeah
yeah but uh you know every once in a
while okay guy got out of hand and you
how to make an example you know it's
just the way it is oh that's you know
now that we don't have but what happened
that we have neighborhoods that we no
one knows anyone know it's not even half
a block like a to build of the Little
Italy now yeah tell me the missus
consumed a goddess club on a mulberry
there was Mulberry Ahmad one or the
other I went by there it's like a
clothing store you know the ravenite so
I wanted today I just you know whose
club this was yeah I see why don't you
have a sign up there John Gotti's former
club US you have people standing outside
they want to come in and buy I don't
want to be associated with that I said
why not
it's business right you don't even know
it's the ravenite when you walk by it
I'm saying that this was John's Club
nothing
Wow crazy do you ever see or talk to
have you talked to Giuliani I I met him
one time
what yeah it was at a
was forget the the oil was a football
organization action actually that it's
out of they have every year they give an
award to top coaches and I had spoke
there a couple of times and he was the
keynote speaker at that time oh yeah it
was okay I always tease him I something
only got a beat you what did you try
yeah and then he fell into themself he
throwing things maybe I'm a truck now
spin it you know to they ask me I you
know the I got a little bit involved in
this whole investigation because I knew
some of the people around Trump and they
asked me if the Trump have a deal with
the mob nicest you guys like you would
never never land
I said he was a developer in New York he
had to deal with us like every other
developer because we control the unions
if you wanted to get anything done you
had to come to us now we didn't party
with him he didn't come to a social club
not that I know if you didn't do it with
me but of course he had to deal with us
you don't get anything done back then
unless you dealt with us what about
Coughlin those guy were you friends with
those scuffle I knew I liked Nicky I
like Nicky yeah he was a good guy I
liked what was his reputation the work
ever the worst yes it's the worst stuff
I like it guy it was always a gentleman
around me yeah we were going to unionize
the bartenders and waitresses in
Atlantic so you can't imagine go to
think they don't need this big yeah it
was tough guy okay he was tough guy he
was he was a man as far as I was
concerned anyway well the guy that
always terrifies me the most from any
mob movie is Joe Pesci in Goodfellas you
know these guys like you know yes I did
he Joe Pesci is the best mob guy a vault
and there's no doubt about it nobody
plays it like him yeah he's the best
so there are guys like that yeah oh yeah
shoot a guy in the foot yeah
at a [ __ ] card game yeah well Jesus
dude
yeah now let me tell you something you
know I the guy told Jill used to hang
out with the guy that got him on the
scene he died I remember you still would
be around John Columbus he was the mob
guy
which guy now I got a really good Joe
Pesci around and the show business and
stuff or Jimmy Burke no the real guy in
the real life
well Jimmy Burke and Joe work were very
close Jesse OH in real life oh oh yeah
you mean the guy did he Frankie Valli no
the guy the guy was the head of the crew
back then I don't know I don't know that
was awful this guy smiley a real Bob I
don't know I brought Joe around he's not
but he Joe knew him I don't know it's
the awesome guy he was awesome guy
remember did you up my team if I met
them they had all those tough guys
around them did you ever meet Mike no we
never met no when I was a kid I met Tony
Solano yeah did you meet Fat Tony insane
cats kill to seek us oh really
yeah it was just I didn't know because
these guys grew up in the same
neighborhood you know I like I'll tell
you a story with Tony he gives me a call
he like me he gives me close me up one
day just come and see me so you know
boss of another family closure you go so
I go to Harlem I go on his club and you
know what Tony looked like a short guy
kind of stocky where the fedora and
smoke the cigar right out of central
casting so it looks at me and he says
hey Mike what are you doing with this
gas business
I said I Tony I'm doing good he should
you make money I said yeah Tony no
complaints I'm making good he's I got
these five mama looks around me they can
turn three sentences like that
he says you give them a job I said yeah
Tony I'll take care don't worry he's
what were you doing I said well I got a
bunch of gas stations how about I put
him in charge of a gas station and
they'll watch it for me he said I said
but Tony don't let them rob me you know
these guys that robbed you I'll cut off
the hands there is but you don't have to
do that this is but just sees it don't
worry
yeah yeah he said he said so he said he
said don't worry about that I said Oh
heshes how much you're gonna pay him so
now I'm thinking I don't want to insult
the boss right it says Tony that's how
about I give me fifteen hundred a week
in cash each he says fifteen hundred
give them five hundred give me the
thousand as you got it dawn oh god he
was he was a character I like them
though he was he was funny guy but he
was he was powerful guy him in a chamber
I'm sure there exist though they were
all characters but listen I think about
this holiday and this is probably a look
at the used to from this given
generation how do you because they're
almost like Kings almost like yeah in
human form
yeah how do they handle that you know
some guys handled it well god I mean
Diamond Jim Esposito I read about him he
used to make sure he he [ __ ] every
virgin before they get married yeah
before they get married he had to [ __ ]
them he got killed eventually but death
was his thing I don't know but it could
be probably and you want to I got it
there was a guy in our family as a
soldier that I was close with there was
two brothers they had two killed their
father they killed him home father
because it was screwing around and other
guys daughter or something so one day
I'm driving were in Brooklyn I'm driving
him home and he gets out of the car and
he said don't leave yet I said alright
so I'm waiting he goes up to the front
doors ringing a bell nobody answers
right he comes back he gets in the car
he says let's go Isis you're not going
in he says nice you don't have a key to
your own house he's not got a key I said
why don't you go in he said cuz nobody's
home I said it's your house he's Michael
he says ever since that incident with my
dad I can't walk in any place in my
house alone I think his ghost is there
it scared the hell out of me he said I
haven't been alone in my house for 30
years that's how it got to him like that
you know we thought like maybe I'm
people had been around
to kill people if I come they never
think it if I ever bring it up this me
what the [ __ ] you're talking about you
crazy [ __ ] are you talking about Mike
and like in the bad with Nick but then
what [ __ ] might think you buggin out
Nick mmm whoa nothing really happy don't
you [ __ ] never happen they're cool
you need anything if they okay me money
or mine cool nothing I put a most part
that's how guys were yeah no that's it
yeah I think yeah that's - it's gone
you know talk about they don't brag
about it don't know my father about it
that's true when my father told me from
a young age if you and I did something
the minute it's done 30 seconds later
you asked me about on what you're
talking about crazy right what the [ __ ]
you talking about my hair yeah they
always think somebody's gonna bring
fitting-out hey then you say this yeah
cuz it's your mouth to get you yeah
let's face it exactly its facial so when
you go and talk to teams about
relationships
what do you talk to him about listen I
always tell them that straight out you
know you are who you hang out with in
this world that's it you put yourself in
the wrong crowd the wrong element you
know you're gonna end up going that no
matter how strong you are you can end up
going that way at some point or you're
gonna be thought to be going that way
because of who you're hanging out with
so you've got to be a leader and not a
follower just stay away from all this
and I always tell them to look 6 9 foot
for 20 years in my life
six nights a week I was in a club always
that's where we hung out
I never seen good stuff happen after
midnight in the club yeah you know
everything that's right that's true
it's not not at midnight but cook
through hooks man yeah Brooks and hooks
that's it and they'll ask me question I
got told I soon let me ask you question
you're standing at a bar you're talking
to a girl with a good time some guy
walks over and he's not spent rude on
you right now you're a tough guy you're
not gonna take it what do you do you get
the guy shot you knock him out he's on
the ground what do you do after that
I said what do you do
I said let me tell you what you're doing
you leave the club get out
why because I can't tell you how many
times I've seen that happen guy leaves
comes back with a gun who comes back and
shoot that's absolutely that's gonna
happen you know me unless he just
knocked out all day on the floor that
happened to a guy in Jacksonville right
right before I got in there this guy
Richard Collier he was a starting right
tackle big guy big huge dick say I had
30 40 was at a club
Thursday night out with some teammates
talking to some girls some dude had a
had a what you would think is nothing an
altercation words exchanged with some
dude
later that night they're sitting in
their car outside this girl's house dude
rolls up shoots into the car drive by
shooting the dude paralyzed yeah I mean
well told him win lose your drug get out
God you don't state sensitive you know
and I feel a masculine he's being
stripped you just Himalayas yeah that's
really the reason why to park got killed
it's not the fact because they really
didn't [ __ ] the guy up because there
were too many people they really
couldn't [ __ ] up the kid baby in a
million [ __ ] ma but he was humiliated
that he was on television that everybody
was [ __ ] on top of him and I him
million them and that's really why he
did it even like Tupac you know but he
was heavily based on him getting the
basket he was but it appeared like
helium stomped out and that's the reason
couldn't handle it is that just a primal
thing shame humiliation yeah we were so
much that even exalt us to success our
shame like you talked about like we
can't you know as fighters as people I
think we we have to we feel this need to
earn honor or to gain honor and we get
it from the whole time anything and the
whole time well we don't realize that
we're bored on earth yeah if you're not
a [ __ ] thief minions by the time you
thin you're not pickpockets snacking
team robbing houses you ain't [ __ ] you
I'm no respect [ __ ] your mother smack
you beat ya ass in front of your parents
your parents or some [ __ ] [ __ ] we're
strikes
shoot yeah every penny I had getting
money if you want some respect you know
you ain't get no respect you're not a
criminal without breaking your house
he's right back then it sound rude yeah
those are the guys that got all the
respect right that was it and you know
you looked up to guys like that yeah
nobody brought the Japan your family and
stuff people knew you little hustle out
the industry get money in our
neighborhood in Greenpoint we never
locked the doors at night there was no
crime if there was any crime in the
neighborhood it was us yes who did it
yeah there was never we never had any
issues like that well how do you tell
these guys to I says if you're gonna
carry a gun do you make sure you know
how to use it and be ready to use it
it's not a showpiece yeah I carry
otherwise don't it'll put you in more
trouble yeah you know yeah you see you
know you see it with the football guys a
lot you know I'll tell you whenever I
leave a party
I'll tell them listen you got a gambling
problem you got an issue email me really
I don't need to know your name I don't
work for the school I'm not part of
enforcement I should email me if I could
help you out I will Evan it's not failed
yet I did over 300 schools by time I get
back to my hotel I've got emails well
every single time yeah you know a lot of
time on my friend is having a problem
right there a basket yeah yeah and it's
all different issues so what do you
think about the guy that don't succeed
the guys that oh dear the guys that get
killed by cops are the guys we killed
wing warfare what are they what were
there now right for Ken oh I can't even
I like to touch us to make us really
this and that where I want to go Oh
I think everybody's here for a purpose I
don't think nobody's here yeah you know
for us Moses yeah the purpose was
somebody's here
the purpose why we're all here together
now I agree with that I know yeah a lot
of things are not by chance no doubt
yeah but you know listen how much time
did you do I did eight years that's the
straight eight no I did five I got out
on parole
I was out 13 months I violated and they
put me back in for another 35 months so
and I did I did 29 months and seven days
in the hole
well if that like I'll be honest that's
not easy no you know anybody tells you
different that's the objective to really
break you make your a game we weren't
meant to be so low we were meant to be
social yes I mean a lot of guys I mean
look I printed I finally really
psychologist at that group people yeah
and the worse thing yeah you know the
only time a guy should be in isolation
if he's a danger to everybody else or a
danger to himself but as I'm especially
these youngsters that they put in it's
terrible what they do because they drive
yet never looking when I was lights went
out at night I heard a lot of moaning
moaning his screaming scream me I'll be
honest with you what got me through you
know I uh I turned that's where I became
a person of faith mmm I had a Bible a
book sent into me and and my faith and
my drive to get home to my family is
what you know kept me sane cuz I got I
lost about 22 pounds I got sick four
times from chicken told me poison from
chicken so I said look I'm not gonna
bring me anything else bring me cereal
bananas and that cup of soup but two
years that's all a cup of soup right of
love couple I still need him what up dad
forget it but uh yeah I couldn't eat
anything but you come out of there some
books so good huh you could get books
[ __ ] again you get newspapers from
maybe five days later so you keep I had
a Sony Walkman but I didn't want you to
want to keep you didn't want to know
what's happening outside they keep
saying five years and a couple of days
later face yes don't know what's going
on you know you had a Sony Walkman and
the only thing I cared about it used to
tell where I was they put the phone in
yourself buddy he could talk but the
only supposed to give you maybe 15
minutes a day so I used to get to God
and he used to put it in my cell at
midnight so I can make calls you know on
even to us it might don't worry about it
leave it but uh you know showers
sometimes you got to showers a week they
pull you out at all they put you in a
shower they lock it sometimes they bring
the SH out to yourself click yeah some
places they do that but I'll tell you
those times they locked me in the shower
and then they got some disturb
and they leave you in here for three or
four hours in there
you know [ __ ] yeah it was tough honestly
it's a tough bid to get through that but
you know you do it got to do it on have
a choice
you guys seen Pappy oh yeah I was all
then undead little Allen yeah yeah
what's that recently and yeah commitment
yeah well he get what he gets thrown
into isolation it's [ __ ] just wall mind
man you have to you have to I mean it it
seems like you would go crazy and a good
putt to his role with he's great movies
it's genius
did you guys ever see the HBO movie
Gotti yeah you saw that right I haven't
seen played guy - what was his name I'm
on the song yes
oh you haven't watched that movie that
was that was on a level of God from
really well that up Anthony kwaini yeah
I was pretty hot you're who - Anthony
plenty played - all right yeah what's
his name got killed it was a country
with cancer yeah I mean he died it
cancer yeah O'Neill della Croce
brilliant he was brilliant and I watched
that movie is one of the best you'll
ever see you guys watch it terrific
really
Dobby I mean I don't know what you have
any more questions from God he's kid
Sammy's kid they ever talk to you I
spoke to junior yes but I was closer
with his daughters and his wife and I
was with Julie Julie was about 10 12
years younger than me yeah when I was on
the street he wasn't coming up yet
now junior doing time right now John jr.
you know he's I know he was going to a
city where they they what they did to
him they took him to trial four or five
times song jewelry's I mean ridiculous
waste of money and time and everything
else and I thought the form of killing
you to this death yeah I guess this is
killing you know stress plus listen I I
was on trial 7 months with Giuliani
7 months I get acquitted cost me well
over a million dollars I had a million
dollar bail between investigators
lawyers and plus I had to prepare for
the case every day
for a year prior to going to trial so
they get you one way together yeah what
was it that made you say I'm out of this
well for me I met a young girl she's now
my wife for 35 years and I met her on a
movie set I was producing but you know I
just realized that the life was over her
as we knew it and big and I became too
high-profile I knew there was they would
never leave me alone until they put me
away forever it would never happen so I
said let me try to make a break I moved
out to California didn't work out I mean
you know everybody got upset with me
yeah how does that go baby
probably can't just well no way no I had
a lot of trouble and a lot of trouble
Mike my former boss he had got convicted
on the mob commission case and he went
Persico he just died in March but uh if
he was on the street I would have had
trouble well he took it very personal
when I left very personal he was very
upset with me was it even on you right
yeah it wasn't something like you can go
and have a conversation you know you
can't you know I would I wouldn't have
left the room yeah you know guys how did
you survive I said well you got to
understand something one of the dangers
of that life is like I said they were
walking in a room you don't walk out
again so I spent 20 years in that life I
knew it intimately well I knew what the
guys were doing what they wouldn't undo
it so what do I do I move out to
California I change my whole lifestyle
what do I mean I don't go on any more
clubs
I don't walk my dog at seven o'clock
every morning I don't go to the same
restaurant every Tuesday night because I
you create a pattern in your life of
guys who looking for you okay we now to
get this guy so I just really was very
disciplined in that and you know it's
one thing to walk you in a room okay
it's another thing to send a hit squad
across the country kill you and get away
with it could you go away for life for
life for murder so and then you know
over a period of years I just outlasted
everybody yeah everybody is dead dead or
in prison everybody yeah did you have a
situation like you know every now and
then you be around it might come in he
made you nervous oh yeah yeah I've seen
you know my antenna was always up so I'm
always watch
and you know I get em - oh my god that
you know and yeah Mike I was in church
in Jersey I stayed out in New York for
ten years right
I go to church I'm speaking at this
church in Jersey and I see three guys
from my life walk in different crew but
I knew them all I said man it's gonna be
my first confrontation right so I walk
right up to him I said what do you guys
want and so we came here to see you I
said what do you want to see me about
it's like the oval came right back right
and he said not we want to hear you
speak I said really he said yeah I said
okay and then their wives walked in
after them so I said okay I said this is
legit as far as why they here but right
away I got I said this is gonna be a
problem you know I mean look I see
somebody that you know cuz look I'm out
there all the time I'm in public
everywhere I speak all over the world
yeah you don't know who's in the air
who's coming up to you signing books and
you see a guy so I'm always kind of
leery you know I'm always watching let's
put it that way you never think of the
guy out there they [ __ ] it for old
times yeah for the old play of boom and
somebody wants to make a name for
himself
you're in a club they notice me make a
call to New York I walk out in a parking
lot boom I'm God you gotta you got to
think about it happen so quick huh yeah
but I mean I don't live in fear I'm
being honest with you I mean you can't
live like that
but I'm aware let's put it that way yeah
that's the fast you know you just have
so much effluences on people you know
mob life they dedicated a whole museum
and they get for it the mob museum yeah
it was awesome till you go through it at
my ass five years oh wow no way every
year that don't know how people come in
there oh yeah that's really interesting
stuff I mean but and they did a good job
with it really it's good they did a
really good job but it's a good place
it's awesome
I have to check that out for sure do you
have any questions from this mic what's
that Mike Mike you know I told him when
I first met her just now I said you know
what I have I have a lot of respect for
Mike because he's just so honest and
sincere
I mean I noticed that over the years
watching you so many times and I respect
him because he's a survivor you know I
went through all of this stuff and look
when you go through all this stuff in
life and you come out you don't have to
stay on top but you come out in a
position you're in now you got to
respect that now I have a lot of respect
for that and I'm not just won't smoke
I'm being honest um I'm just grateful
you know I don't know what's going to
happen sometimes you know I was just I
was just rerun relapse on drugs an old
diesel year ago you know you know it's
all about giving up yeah it's submitting
to life and I tell someone to see him
you see he was a man of faith I think
everybody even the atheist when it comes
some part of their life to come - well I
do believe I'm a believer
yeah and you can't die you know if you
have any kind of um real logic of who
you are it's almost I I don't know but
I'm not people think how do you die
because you believe in it there's no
greater greater being than you did you
the greatest force in the world and it's
not greater than you did you have to bow
- how did you go to your grave thinking
down it's hard I'll tell you what my
that night that they walked me in that
room I was I grew up as a Catholic but I
wasn't religious at all but I was
praying man you think you're meeting
your maker you worry how do you dev you
but that's what this is what I want to
ask you have you been around like this
thing you know and this guy's give me
the dice on yeah like we all hanging on
the clovers in here we are drinking
talking you know it's got a good I'm
probably 20 minutes if not an hour and
be lucky in an hour huh
yeah it's it's it's tough it really is I
mean you got to be you got to have kind
of an animal nature if it doesn't bother
you you know look you know I did things
in our life that were very unpleasant
but what you do is you know my you kind
of step outside of yourself for a minute
life yeah yeah beg him DC you [ __ ]
smell the [ __ ] when they dining [ __ ]
comes out most of the time they don't
know what's happening you know if they
walked in a room it's boom and that's
the end of that you know they don't even
know but I mean I've seen guys pretty
scared and they walked in the room said
everything will be all right Mike and
there's my fear that yeah but on the way
there it makes everything will be all
right yes
good you know it's it's it's not a good
feeling you know some guys that feel
that they know something that happened
you feel that do they know something's
gonna happen there oh yeah yeah when you
get that sense it's it's tough you know
you can't mask you I'll kill who you are
yeah you can't mask that mother I must
be a pig when that happened you must see
something's different today you have to
feel that feeling you know something
that's different today
you mean I know you got a Dobby Missy
something's different - yeah who knows
yeah
cus my my mentor is funny he knew
Italians and looser mob guy but he
always disliked them obviously the only
people with Italian people he was mad at
that he didn't like that cuts was one of
those old Italian point in 1906 like you
know those guys from seaboard in the
u.s. cus I think so yeah he was the only
one pointing at me work yeah but um he's
the kind of Italian guy that said like
if he looked at these guys one of those
guys Pauly D in those guys what's those
guys name what's it come on you know
Paula Deen those guys who shows you know
I'm talking about Jersey Shore Jersey
Shore like cuz he's the older guy so he
thinks 70 60 or 70 if he feeds Jersey
Shore here say they're not Italians
uh-huh they're not Italian and so I
would never saintly you can send both of
us in another Italian in my mind well
how does he look the doesn't mean
they're not Italians but he had that
play Titans had dignity and pride it's
just like the worst show on ever was Mob
Wives oh my god I saw that it just yeah
what was the deal with that
Mike they weren't even mob wipes I don't
know what they were you know i I've
never seen anything like that Milo it
was horrible and I have won three or
four seasons yeah baby still going no I
don't die don't die oh might be I hope
not
it got me sick did you know this girl no
I I knew Sammy Gravano store yeah yeah I
know
and I knew well Gregg scope is thought
it was an in it but we did an interview
together once but that was a sick [ __ ]
and it was probably like now it's a
charade ridiculous
I mean look first of all Mob Wives they
didn't know anything we never said a
word that I'm about anything they do not
then you know and girlfriend maybe knows
a little bit more but the wife never
nothing interesting that you said when
those dudes came into the church and you
saw their wives you knew that yeah yeah
yeah mob guy you know he's always been
in the mob like guys like Al Capone and
John Gotti and you see John Gotti is
neither a DJ I believe I was watching on
YouTube and he still to this day she's
trying to clean that name
everybody's cleaning their name up he'd
be [ __ ] all them stop using the name
Al Capone then you always always follow
them I mean and then when she doesn't
then people look at like what the [ __ ]
give me I Capone's the [ __ ] man what
are you trying to clean up [ __ ] his
image up you know that's the people look
men men look a guy like Al Capone's [ __ ]
you mean what's wrong with him and a
boss that's what they that God is a boss
what's wrong with him he gave us our
ball if I manhood what the [ __ ] you know
I I hear more today because of the state
of our government you're gonna tell you
how many guys said the mob would have
run the government
I mean to run the country but in them I
go absolutely ic- it was better when the
mob had Vegas all the old-school guys
fada it was better than forget about
there's no robbery no gang bangers
shootouts out here you can't even you
can't even get a meal on a cop you got
to spend $100,000 to get a meal nothing
when we ran with Natalie backing away by
faith definitely got the puff thing back
in the day there's so much better but
everybody says that so when you guys we
never are spills I want the benefit so
much better
no muggins it's so interesting yeah
you're too young to remember but back in
the seventies name I love Vegas back
then you were free we adapted that you
knew not to [ __ ] with nobody you knew
right [ __ ] you know you come in with
these way Italians don't [ __ ] with them
we know that the [ __ ] we'd be fine
missing some [ __ ] away
you know you never be seen again that
kind of [ __ ] Wow
well Michael it's been a pleasure huh
what do you do my where are you going
right now what's that oh no I Thursday I
go to Alabama I'm gonna speak it oh yeah
that's awesome I got that I got a couple
more schools this year dand you know I
speak in churches a lot my cab writing
books got a book for you about Evan I
didn't know I would have brought one but
I'm sorry
yes I got your address I love it to you
and Frenchy and love them you know I'm
doing a television show Italians are
people from the neighborhood not who
will not mob-related but the deep end
too but they're not you know in the mall
did they say hey you made the right
decision or yeah I really feel that way
but they can't faint but can't say right
I you know yes sir
flame before me you know your owned by
people so I'm doing that I'm going on
tour in in United Kingdom in October so
I'll be in Cabo next week I'm gonna go
down there for a week to rest voice and
that's it you know life is good no
complaints still have your challenges
and struggles you know but you didn't
ask to stop yeah so as you know one date
in the next you never know yeah but you
think about you must figure out all the
ships I said that this really actually
exists I think about my life I said
wiped all these tough guys on the corner
and hanging did this really actually
exist
it was fun life a lie that's really what
happened oh you knew you never seen
anybody in a corner no no with a loss or
people hanging on in the corner you only
knew where to find somewhere you go to
the cornet Shack gonna find nobody yeah
you don't even let your kids out in the
front of the house too late yeah can't
believe gunfire I mean honestly that's
why I don't do gun scared for my and I'm
having a great neighbor I missed
anything I have a gunfire on the skin
nothing better happen over there Mike
so yeah yeah we got to get together out
there I would love for sure yeah I live
a course three from Fashion Island right
over there and I'm in a pile again hell
yeah yeah do you golf Mike yeah we go no
is that a monarch odd Mahna Mahna Mahna
got beautiful you know Nixon one oh
that's right you know what my son was
telling me but I was out of town he said
like seven is that's right at monarch
like this for sure about how
thoughtfully my wife want to buy a house
over there I was beautiful we're in mana
cuz monarch is beautiful yeah yeah
really nice that whole area how can you
beat it
hey you like you have horses back in the
day they run I had a Trotter know that
this thing work you know man abhi I saw
a horse in the other day the beautiful
sauce in the world I said I want the
whole thing that off my dough my cost
about so this horse since the most
people are gonna buy it I'm gonna get on
the web and keep it I'm gonna take it
home with me put it in the backyard
somewhere what a tenth of an acre where
qahal attackee is Arabian horse Arabian
horse what's it called come in here both
car a car attack e are you gonna tell
you right now [ __ ] up right now
because I'm fall in love with this hell
I don't know what my dried horses no
love with it yeah it's the oldest horse
breed to ever live where they want for
you know six only ten thousand dollars
but it's let them to be a bit yeah good
stage I'm livin in Tustin right around
here we got horse they told me I
to close by was gonna be like two
million dollars there's a good rise find
out for you huh yeah love that you're
gonna be riding it
I'm a ain't gonna hold it kiss it Walker
I want to get it I want to get a young
baby around six months or something it's
beautiful horse it's beautiful
look it's born like that with metallic
fur it's born like they're all of them
as metallic for firm look at the ish
and they don't have no septimius fat no
they're all muscle there's no feather
you know thoroughbred have fat and they
burn the fat of this have no fat on it
well no fat nobody's fat was well if
total muscle 100 the same muscle
understand incredible
that's the next thing of this is my next
love I love it they do you have a horse
ranch
I don't know but on our property we
could put a horse man yeah well you you
get that horse you're gonna be one
around it all the time well that's all I
want to I want to do you want to be
around am but I think it we should get
to yeah you have to be a little serene
oh yeah I've never been like crazy look
at this [ __ ] man see the metallic fur
fur on them I never been this big and
they got 12 packs look at him look no
[ __ ] fat golly that is beautiful
there's 7,000 years old wow that's
amazing
a cult techie and all day I never heard
of it they fought against the I'm the
Russian Empire and the Russians beat
them and so they took all the horses
it's amazing Mike you have to take it
well F to do a hot box and at the horse
ranch yeah I like to do that I'd be joke
I don't even know why I never wanted to
have never thought about I was didn't
think about race Mike he's won a
pathetic when did you see it
three days ago well he called while I
was on a YouTube and I saw this thing's
made settings more beautiful animals in
the world
let's check this [ __ ] out I'm animal
guys that fight
I've seen the white minding their stuff
and then I realized the way mining them
from nature perspective is interesting
is a mistake huh something so beautiful
is a mistake so God made a mistake from
that beautiful and so we went to the
horse and I thought a horse and I said
holy [ __ ]
I'm that that one I wanted a [ __ ] I
never had a horse never was crazy about
horses any I'm what that well it's all
mr. beauty no net all the calls to it
and everything and then I gotta go to
this plate come Turkestan where they
originate from you're going there yeah
is that your next trip there's a couple
weeks
is it not I'll make it part of it okay
before it gets too cold
yeah it's awesome them great time well
thank you so mad you found me of it yeah
okay that might really glad you came
yeah we got to get together I could I
get my Frenchie we'll meet up out there
absolutely yeah I know who he is yeah
Mike I'll take us out for watching and
listening everybody be sure to subscribe
to our YouTube channel hot boxing with
Mike Tyson check out our website hot
boxing podcast calm until next time I'll
never Britain I'm Mike Tyson I'm Mike
Francie's do you want anybody know where
you at talk to you it's okay I'm all
over YouTube Michael Franzese calm I'm
on Facebook Twitter the whole bit so you
you want to get in touch with me you
don't have to go through Mike and come
directly yeah hit him direct alright
everybody right here okay
[Music]
[Music]